you're known to like do collab projects
with people who's somebody who you
haven't worked with on
like a full album that you would like to
do like a full like
tape with oh man ice work that's
opposite to a cd
fire shout out to detroit yeah supposed
to do a whole cd
uh that's the only thing that i had on
my schedule that's why i'm surprised you
and bernie never did a
full joint uh
that should be crazy for the bay do you
man burn don't [ __ ] with me like that
really you're real yeah yeah you don't
[ __ ] with me like that
obviously personally without the burner
but now bernie said this my guy but
the the cam i'm not the chemistry he's
not [ __ ] you guys just never
got like just oh we've been around each
other you guys just never
vibed no we vibe but
i don't know it's just something it's
something there that
you feel me that it ain't being being
talked about what
i mean i'm easy i didn't i didn't say
this plenty of times you know
to to the inside people just feel like
burned on [ __ ] with a [ __ ] like that
he's a good he's a he's a great dude
though
like he's a he's a good dude he didn't
do big shows
of course he feels he's never involved
um you know he didn't do a lot of um
stuff for the store or whatever cookies
and all that field he's never involved
so i'll just be like i mean just like we
like i said you talk about the king oak
stuff like we know who's popping what's
going on
so if you're not supporting the hottest
person in the bay like
it got to be something do you do you
think because i feel like i mean
obviously taking
that out aside on you know unbiased
but do you feel like for whatever reason
like i feel like
burn is another one of those guys like
you who's just been killing [ __ ] for a
long time i ain't doing this thing
i just feel but i have no issue with you
feel like he's slept on
in hip hip-hop because i feel like he
doesn't hit him i feel like sometimes he
just doesn't like
when people mention the bae like for
whatever reason
we all know him for weed and cookies but
like musically like he's been doing his
thing for so long and i feel like
sometimes i don't i don't i don't really
know because keep it real like
no disrespect i'm not really in tune to
the music so i don't really know um
if he's being slapped on or not like we
didn't dumb music before like
i was on the project with him and dolph
yeah he didn't done a song for me before
in a video whatever but
that's as far as it went yeah i'm saying
so other than that
you know i didn't went to the store
before cookies or whatever i just left
the cookie store
right where we got here so it's not like
it's not something like
yeah but i just i just feel like you
know it's just something in between like
i even talked to
people that's close to him right right
white brother don't [ __ ] with me like
that you know what i'm saying so
that's fair yeah yeah hopefully you guys
you know yeah he's doing his things
i mean i can take the game from him as
in the clothing the wii
you know